[موسيقى]
عام مر على الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
بالنسبه الى الكثيرين سيبقى الرابع
والعشرون من فبراير شباط 2022 يوما محفورا
في ذاكرتهم الى الابد فقد خلفت الحرب
خسائر كبيره في صفوف العسكريين والمدنيين
من الجانبين وادت الى موجه لجوء ونزوح
جماعي وصفتها الامم المتحده بانها اكبر
واسرع حركه سكانيه قصريه في اوروبا منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه وبعد عام لا يزال
الغموض يكتنف مصير هذه الحرب التي رفعت
منسوبه التوتر بين موسكو والغرب الى اعلى
مستوياته على الاطلاق الشيء الوحيد المؤكد
حتى الان وان السلام لا يزال بعيدا المنال
في غياب اي مؤشرات على الرغبه في التراجع
او تقديم تنازلات من الطرفين او التوصل
الى تسويه تفاضيه فما هي المسارات
المحتمله التي قد تسلكها هذه الحرب في
الثاني ومع احتمالات توسع نطاقها الجغرافي
بما يهدد السلم والامن الدوليين اهلا بكم
في هذه الحلقه من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم
شكلت الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا الحدث
الابرز عالميا على مدى العام المنصرم ومع
استمرارها ومعاناه العديد من دول العالم
من تبعاتها خاصه في مجال الطاقه والغذاء
تتركز الانظار على معرفه مصيرها ومساراتها
المحتمله في عامها الثاني عن التوقعات
والسيناريوهات العسكريه او السياسيه
المحتمله لهذه الحرب خلال الاشهر المقبله
يسعدنا ان نستضيف هنا في الاستوديو في هذه
الحلقه العميده ليسحنى الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي من باريس سمنتا
الباحثه في المعهد الملكي للشؤون الدوليه
ومن موسكو المحلل السياسي
افقيني سيدي روفا اهلا بهم جميعا
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا التي يعتبرها
حلف الناتو اكبر تهديد للامن الاوروبي
الاطلسيه منذ عقود شهدت تطورات عديده على
مدى عام كامل فيما يلي اهم وابرز محطاتها
الرئيسيه
[موسيقى]
قبل عام دوت صفارات الانذار في العاصمه
كييف وغيرها من المدن الاوكرانيه منذره
ببدء حرب لا تزال اصداؤها تتردد في مختلف
انحاء العالم
[موسيقى]
بدا القصف المدفعي والجوي بعد دقائق من
خطاب للرئيس الروسي استعر القتال وارتفعت
الخسائر في صفوف الجانبين تعرض الجيش
الروسي لسلسله من الاخفاقات دفعت الكرملين
الى اعاده ترتيب اولوياته ومراجعه حساباته
وفي اواخر مارس الماضي شرعت القوات
الروسيه في الانسحاب من ضواحي كيف وركزت
مجهودها الحربيه على المناطق الشرقيه
والجنوبيه
وبعد حصار طويل ومدمر استولت على مدينه
ماريوبول الاستراتيجيه في محاوله لتامين
ممر على طول ساحل البحر الاسود يربط شبه
جزيره القرم باقليم دومباس
مضت القوات الاوكرانيه بشن هجمات مضاده ما
ادى الى تراجع القوات الروسيه في اجزاء من
الجنوب والشرق بفضل كميات غير مسبوقه من
الاسلحه المتطوره حصلت عليها من الدول
الغربيه
لعبت الطائرات دون الطيار دورا مهما في
هذا الصراع حيث استخدم العديد منها منذ
بدايه الحرب للمراقبه والاستهداف من قبل
الطرفين وفي الاشهر الاخيره استخدمت روسيا
عددا كبيرا منها لمهاجمه المدن ومحطات
الطاقه الاوكرانيه كما استعانت بوحدات من
ميليشيا فاجنر ومع دخول الحرب عامها
الثانيه يبدو الغرب اكثر اصرارا على تكفيف
الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا كمن ونوعا فقد
ارتفعت نبره الخطاب الامريكي ورافقتها
خطوات ومواقف تشير الى ان الاداره
الامريكيه تتجه نحو التزويد كييف تدريجيا
بمزيد من الاسلحه الثقيله والنوعيه وهو ما
اكده الرئيس الامريكي في خطابه بوارسو
ووزير الخارجيه في مؤتمر ميونخ في غضون
ذلك يواصل الرئيس الاوكراني حث حلفاء
الغربيين على ضروره الاسراع في ارسال
الامدادات العسكريه لتعزيز قدره قوته على
صد الهجمات الروسيه
ومعدم وجود بوادر للتسويه سياسيه في الافق
المنظور واسراء الغرب على ضروره الحاق
الهزيمه بروسيا مقابل اصرار الرئيس الروسي
على عدم التراجع وتاكيده ان من المستحيل
هزيمه بلاده في ارض المعركه تبدو الامور
متجهه نحو مزيد من التصعيد خصوصا مع حديث
الامين العام لحلف الاطلسي عن هجوم الروسي
مرتقب واسع النطاق في الربيع وبالنظر الى
تجفيف الدعم العسكري الغربي لكييف الاونه
الاخيره تتزايد المخاوف من تحول هذه الحرب
الى صدام مباشر او مواجهه شامله بين روسيا
والنيتو او حتى خروجها عن نطاق السيطره
واتجاهها نحو مستوى خطير من التصعيد قد
يدفع روسيا الى الخيار النووي كما توعد
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين مرارا بوقف ما سماه
التهديد الوجودي لبلاده مؤكدا ان الامر
ليس خدعه
العميد اهلا وسهلا بك شكرا على استقباله
اهلا وسهلا
عسكريا ما الذي يمكن ان تاتي به حرب
اوكرانيا وهي تدخل عمها الثاني
محمد اوكرانيا كما يقال او كما شهدنا غيرت
العالم يعني غيرت المنظومه الامنيه
باوروبا غيرت روسيا وحتى غيرت اوكرانيا
بحديثاتها اليوم اذا اعتبرنا ان هناك اربع
مراحل مرت فيها اوكرانيا من كييف الى
الدومباس الى الجنوب نحن اليوم في مرحله
جديده يرسم لها يعني يجب ان نقرا زياره
الرئيس بايدن لكياف خطابه وخطاب الرئيس
بوتين وكاننا امام مرحله كما ذكر رئيس
بوتين مرحله
التوقف او توقيف معاهده ستارت النوويه
وكاننا نحن اليوم بالمعنى الجيو السياسي
الكبير نحضر لحرب مهمه ولكن دائما في
التكتيك هناك تحضيرات اساسيه ان كان من
الجهه الروسيه او حتى من الجهه الاوكرانيه
ومنهم من يقول محمد ان الحرب او الهجوم
الروسي قد بدا فعلا في الشرق ولكنه يتعثر
في امكنه معينه ولكن للنجاح هناك ظروف
معينه تعتمد على التوازن بين الاهداف
الموضوعه الجيو سياسيه كما حددها الرئيس
بوتين او حتى حددها الرئيس بايدن ولكن
يبقى ما هي الوسائل العديد العتاد
الجهوزيه العقيده العسكريه واين ستنفذ هذه
العمليات عندما يتحدث البعض عن ان الربيع
قريب وان هذا سيعطي دفعه جديده للمعارك
لاي مدى هذا دقيق عسكريا عاده يقال انه في
حتى في اوكرانيا هي تجربه تاريخيه منذ
ايام الحرب العالميه الاولى
الثانيه اليوم عندما يكون هناك جليد وثلج
كثيف يمكن القيام بعمليات مناوره الحديث
اليوم عن الربيع هو ذوبان هذه هذا الجليد
وذوبان هذه الثلوج ليتشكل الوحل وهو
العائق الاساسي ليس مهما الى درجه متقدمه
ولكنه عاقل اساسي امام العمليات العسكريه
من هنا قد يمكن القول ان الهجوم الروسي
بدا ولكن لجهزيه العسكر الاوكراني والجيش
الاوكراني قد تتحدث عن ادار المقبل وحتى
نيسان بالنسبه للبعض سيد سيدي روف في
موسكو
روسيا تعثرت في هذه الحرب ولم تستطع ان
تحسمها بسرعه رغم الفرق في موازين القوى
هل يمكن لها ان تتغير هذه الصوره في العام
الثاني للحرب
تحيه لك ولساده المشاهدين
والاعتقد ان صوره يمكن ان تتغير خلال
السنه الثانيه اولا لانه عندما بدات روسيا
الى عمليه ربما كانت بحاجه قبل ان تبدا
بها كانت بحاجه الى تركيز على الامور
الاساسيه المتعلقه
بالتكتيك المرتقب في اثناء هذه العمليه
ولكن يبدو انه كانت هناك افاوات وحتى
اخطاء ادت الى بعض التراجعات لا شك ان
روسيا والجيشها استفاد بسرعه من هذه العبر
مثل ما كان هناك ايضا هفوات في اثناء
عمليه التعبئه الجزئيه ايضا اكتشفت هناك
عدد من الثغرات ولكن لكنه تم تصحيحها وكل
هذه الامور واخيرا تغيير القياده العسكريه
في بدايه السنه حيث ان قياده الجنرال
لم تكن ربما فعاله براي البعض لا شيما في
قياده وزاره الدفاع رغم ان السوراميك تمكن
من
الحفاظ على عدد من القوات الروسيه اثناء
انسحابها من مدينه خرسون ولكن التطورات
اللاحقه تطلبت ان يكون هناك تغيير وهذا
تغيير جاء وتمثله في تعيين رئيس هيئه
الاركان العامه للجيش الروسي سيد جيراشيمو
فلي قياده العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
وربما هذا التعيين له دلالات لان يبدو ان
مثل هذا
مثل هذا الرجل وهو محنط جدا في التكتيك
والاستراتيجيه لا شك انه يدرك تماما كل
خصائص وميزات وربما بعض الامور الحساسه
التي قد يصطدم بها الجيش الروسي في اثناء
العام الثاني من العسكريه وقبل ان تبدا
هناك اي عمليه ومثلا اي هجوم واسعه النطاق
لا شك انه سيكون مدروسا مسبقا لازاله كل
ثغرات او الاخطاء التي يمكن ان تحدث كما
كان ذلك في بدايه العمليه العسكريه هذا
بالنسبه لروسيا ماذا عن الغرب السيده
سمنتا اذا اخذنا ما قاله جون بولتون
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي السابق قال
ليست للغرب استراتيجيه للنصر هل هذا
سيتواصل حتى في العام الثاني
اعتقد ان السيد بولتن هو محق في البدايه
الغرب لم تكن لديهم استراتيجيه من اجل
النصر في حقيقه الامر الغرب ليس لديه
استراتيجيه بالنسبه لاوكرانيا على خلاف ما
تعتقده روسيا انا كنت اعمل في مقر الرئيسي
بالنسبه للنيتو وهم يتحدث عن كيفيه اعطاء
اوكرانيا الضمانات المطلوبه دونما ازعاج
روسيا في بدايه الحرب اعتقد بان الغرب فكر
بانك يابسه تسقط وبسرعه كبيره لكن عندما
راى الغرب صمود الشعب الاوكراني تغيرت
المساله اذا اريد ان اعطيكم مثالا عن قريه
اسمها سني حيث انه لم يكن هناك اي قوات
اوكرانيه وكانت العمليه التي كانوا فيها
يدافعون عن اراضيهم حيث ان الروس كانوا
يعتقدون ان هناك
للجيش الاوكراني في هذه المنطقه وعندما
راى الغرب ان اوكرانيا كانت جاهزه وقادره
على الدفاع عن نفسها بداوا بمساعده
اوكرانيا لسبب بسيط ان الكثير من الدول في
اوروبا الشرقيه التي هي عضو شعر انهم تحت
تهديد المباشر لكن انتم محقون روسيا لديها
استراتيجيه بشان اوكرانيا روسيا تريد ان
تقوم بغزو اوكرانيا والسيطره عليها اعتقد
انه في الاشهر القليله الماضيه بالتاكيد
منذ بدايه هذه السنه الغرب يبدو انه يقترب
من الحصول على استراتيجيات تتاكد من
خلالها ان اوكرانيا لا يتم السيطره عليها
من قبل روسيا ولا تسقط كييف بين ايديهم هل
فعلا عميد الياس حنا لمست ذلك بان روسيا
لديها استراتيجيه واضحه والغرب مضطرب الى
حد ما وقد يصلح ذلك في القريب محمد يعني
كل الافرقه لديهم استراتيجيات يعني انت
تضع الاستراتيجيه لتنفيذ اهداف سياسيه
المشكله ان الكل لديه ولكن هذه استراتيجيه
متطوره لينه يعني تتطور وتتحدث مع
الوقائع الميدانيه الرئيس بوتين وضع
اهدافا سياسيه كبيره جدا جدا جدا حتى طلب
ان تعود يعود النيتو الى التسعينات هذا
امر مستحيل اثنين يريد ان يلغي اوكرانيا
ثلاثه هذه الاهداف الكبيره
السياسيه ولكن خصص لها وسائل متواضعه مع
عدم اداء جيد بالمعنى الاستراتيجي بالمعنى
العملي وبالمعنى التكتي على كل الجبهه
التي امتدت ما يقارب الالفين كلم وبالتالي
هو عمليه تغيير مستمر لهذه الجبهه ولكن
الغرب كان واضحا كما يقال بالوضوح
الاستراتيجي الرئيس بايدن قال لا امريكي
يقاتل على الارض الاوكرانيه لا لسلاح يضرب
الداخل الاوكراني الروسي ولكن كان هناك
يستنتج من هذه العمليه المقاربه التاليه
لا يجب ان يربح بوتين كي لا يهدد اوروبا
ويغير النظام العالمي القائم هذا امر
اثنين ولكنه لا يجب ان يخسر بطريقه مذله
كي لا يذهب الى التصعيد والوصول حتى
النووي وهذا امر مهم جدا الكل لديه
استراتيجيه وانا لا اعتقد ان هناك الغرب
يعمل بدون استرته والدليل على ذلك اكثر من
30 مليار من السلاح يقدم اليوم لاوكرانيا
فاذا من ضمن استراتيجيه معينه
سنتوقف عند النووي لان التطور خطير
والتعدد الاشارات اليه باشكال مختلفه ولكن
ما الذي يمكن سواء لروسيا او لاوكرانيا ان
تقوم به عسكريا في الفتره المقبله ولم تكن
تفعله في السابق
استاذ محمد اولا يجب ان نعتبر الاهداف
الروسيه كبيره جدا ولكن الوسائل قليله
بالمقابل الاهداف الاوكرانيه تحرير كل
اوكرانيا كبيره جدا مع الاهداف مع الوسائل
المتواضعه هنا تبدا الاستراتيجيات بوضع
الاولويات ما هي اولويه الرئيس بوتين وما
هي اولويه الاوكران الجيش الاوكراني اليوم
عندما نتحدث عن اولويات الرئيس بوتين
بالحد الادنى يجب تنفيذ المرسوم الذي ضم
فيه الاقاليم الاربعه وبالتالي استكمال
استيلاء على ما تبقى من الدنيا
وحتى القليل من خرسان لماذا لانه بالعقل
الروسي وبعقل الرئيس بوتين يعتبر هذه
الارض هي ارض الروسيه لابد من الدفاع عنها
ولديه الدعم الداخلي من الجهه الاوكرانيه
ايضا الاهداف كبيره ولكن الوسائل
الاساسيه ضعيفه فاذا من هنا الهدف الاسمى
لاوكرانيا ان تهاجم من جهه زابولوجيا
ميليتوبول الى البحر الاسود الى حدود شبه
جزيره قرم وبالتالي التفاوض في مرحله
لاحقه هذا بالحد الادنى الرئيس بوتين
سيدروف مؤخرا اكد انه
ستتحقق اهداف الحرب يعني ما الذي يجعل
الرئيس بوتين متفائلا الى هذا الحد في حين
انه الى حد ما فشل في ان
يكسب هذه الحرب طوال عام كامل
الذي يجعل الرئيس بوتين متفائلا كما تفضلت
استاذ محمد هو ان هناك كما قلت
استفاده من الدروس والعبر التي تم الكشف
عنها في اثناء السنه الاولى كما قلت انا
في البدايه روسيا القوات الروسيه معروفه
بالاستفاده من اخطائها وهفواتها وهزم يحدث
الان مثلا المعارك التي تدور حول بخموت من
جهه نرى انها شرسه وربما عنيفه جدا ولكن
من جهه اخرى نرى بما ان تقدم القوات
الروسيه بطيء وربما كما يقول بعض القدر
العسكريين المعارك تدور حول كل متر او
عشره امتار ربما كيلومتر ولكن بنفس الوقت
القياده العسكريه الروسيه الان تولي
اهتماما بالغا جدا
للحفاظ على حياه العسكريين
لان هذا الامر هو من اهم الاولويات
بالنسبه طبعا لتكتيك التي تتبعها القياده
العسكريه الجديده كما ان ما يجعل الرئيس
بوتين متفائلا الان
هو ان هذه العمليه تعتمد الان على ربما
العناصر التي جاءت في ظل التعبئه الجزئيه
فرغم بعض الهفوات والعيوب التي اكتشفت
خلال هذه العمليه يبدو ان خيره
العسكريين الذين يحاربون الان في عدد من
الجبهات العشيه في جبهه جنوب شرقيه
اوكرانيا هم تدربوا بشكل
بشكل جيد وهم مستعدين لتنفيذ المهام
المطروحه امامهم ويبدو ان هذه المهام في
هذه المرحله بالذات ربما تتمثل في اقامه
السيطره الكامله على منطقه التي تشمل كما
هو معروفه
دونيتسكو وعدد من المناطق
مجاوره لهما
بالنسبه للغرب سيد سمنتها
واضح ان
الدول الغربيه الولايات المتحده اوروبا
كلها تدعم اوكرانيا ولكن ظلت حذره في
موضوع الاسلحه النوعيه في كل مره هناك جدل
حول الاسلحه حول الذخيره هذا من ناحيه
وحذر ايضا
فيما يتعلق باستهداف الاراضي الروسيه هل
سيظل هذا هذان الحذران متواصلين في العام
الثاني للحرب
لقد شهدنا منذ بدايه الحرب ان النوع
الاسلحه التي تم تسليمها الى اوكرانيا
زادت من حيث القدرات لمساعده اوكرانيا على
الدفاع عن نفسها والان نتحدث عن تسليم
دبابات التي ستساعد اوكرانيا على استرجاع
اراضيها والان لابد ان نميز ما بين
الاسلحه الدفاعيه والهجوميه والكثير من
المحللين وانا محلله مستقله واريد ان اؤكد
على هذه النقطه الكثير من المحللين يقولون
عندما تدافع دوله عن اراضيها من جهه
هجوميه فانه ليس هناك فرق ما بين اسلحه
هجوميه والدفاعيه وبالتالي هم يقولون ان
الاسلحه لابد ان لا تضرب الارا الروسيه
لان هذا يعتبر مبعث قلق بالنسبه
للغرب لان الغرب لا يريد ان يدخل في حرب
مع روسيا اريد ان اخبر من يتابعون هذا
البرنامج في نهايه السنه الماضيه كان هناك
الصاروخ قد وقع على الاراضي
البولنديه وكلى الطرفين كل من بولندا
والنيتو والروسيا وبشكل فوري كانوا توقين
ليجعلوا كل الاطراف متاكده بان هذه
الصواريخ او هذا الصاروخ ليس روسيا لانه
كان هناك مخاطره قد تؤدي الى التصعيد
وبالتالي كان هناك التحقق من الامر تحقق
من ان
يوضحوا الامر حتى لا يكون هناك اي تصعيد
بالنسبه للمقاتلات هم يحتاجون اليها من
اجل الدفاع عن اراضيهم السبب الذي يجعل
الدول الغربيه لا ترغب في تسليم هذه
الطائرات لانهم يريدون ان يحصلوا على
ضمانات ان اوكرانيا لن تستخدم هذه
الطائرات
لتستهدف اهدافا داخل الاراضي الروسيه كان
هناك الزياده تدريجيه بالنسبه للاسلحه
التي وفرت لاوكرانيا للدفاع عن نفسها واذا
كنت لاتوقع اعتقد ان اوكرانيا ستحصل على
طائرات لانها
لان الغرب يقول انه يريد ان يدفع بروسيا
بعيدا عن الاراضي التي لدى اوكرانيا سياده
عليها ولكن مجددا وهنا اؤكد على هذه
المساله العواصم الغربيه هي واضحه تجاه
اوكرانيا الان السؤال الذي يطرح ما هي
الاراضي الروسيه لانه لدينا الاتحاد
الروسي كما هو معترف به وكما هو معترف به
حسب حدوده الدوليه لكن الروسيه تتحدث عن
مناطق قامت بضمها مؤخرا مثل شبه جزيره
القرم التي تعتبرها روسيا روسيا ولا
تعتبرها اوكرانيا روسيه واذا ما استمعنا
الى القاده الغربيين الحكومات والمستشارين
الغربيين هم
يجلسون في منطقه صعبه جدا عندما يتعلق
الامر بشبه جزيره القرم عندما يتعلق الامر
بفيكتوريا لم يستبعد في مقابله اجرعه
مؤخرا فكره ان اوكرانيا ربما قد يكون
لديها اسلحه ربما قد تستهدف بها شبه جزيره
القرم لكن الغرب سيكون غير راغب بان يرى
اوكرانيا تحصل على الاسلحه التي تمكنناها
من استرجاع شبه جزيره القرم من ناحيه
العسكريه لكن هذا التحليل هو تحليل مستقل
هذا الموضوع تحديدا العميد الياس موضوع
الاسلحه هذا الحذر الغربي يريد من
اوكرانيا ان تدافع عن اراضيها ولكنه في كل
خطوه سواء في الدباب ات او في الذخيره
والان موضوع الطيران
يزن المعادله بشكل
دقيق جدا
هل سيتواصل نفس الاسلوب حتى الان في بدايه
العام الثاني للحرب دعنا نقول محمد ان
هناك استراتيجيه قدم الخطوط الحمر الروسيه
الموضوعه وحسب العقل الامريكي والقرار
الامريكي وهذا قاله وزير الدفاع الامريكيه
نحن نعطي السلاح استنادا الى مبادئ معينه
اولا ماذا يتطلب الواقع الميداني يعني
بالمرحله الاولى كان هناك
كان هناك كان هناك المسيرات بالمرحله
الثانيه الهايمرز اليوم المرحله دبابات
فماذا عن المرحله القادمه يعني نعطي
السلاح حسب ماضي يتطلبه الواقع الميداني
اثنين ان يكون الجيش الاوكراني قادرا على
استعماله وتعهده وبالتالي تشغيله البعد
الثالث وهنا الامر المهم ان لا يشكل هذا
الامر تصعيدا لدى الروسيه وبالتالي الذهاب
الى ما
ليس في الحسبان هذه المعادله الاساسيه
سنتوقف فيما يتعلق بهذه الاشارات للخيار
النووي لان الان اذا ذهبنا في مثل هذا
الخيار ولو بشكل او باخر فالخسائر ستكون
كبيره رغم ان الخسائر اصلا هي مرتفعه لان
مع استمرار الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
واجتداد الضرواتها ومحاوله كل طرف تحقيق
مكاسب على الارض يرجح ان ترتفع حصيله
الخسائر البشريه في صفوف العسكريين
والمدنيين من الجانبين الروسي والاوكراني
لكن الارقام تبقى مع ذلك متباينه بين
المصادر الروسيه والغربيه وتقارير الامم
المتحده فيما يلي جرد لهذه الخسائر على
مدى عام من هذه الحرب
وفقا لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه فان عدد قتل
الجيش الروسي حتى نهايه شهر سبتمبر الماضي
بلغ نحو سته الاف جندي بينما قالت مصادر
عسكريه امريكيه ان التقديرات تشير الى
مقتل مئات وثمانين الف عسكري روسي خلال
عام 2022 على الجانب الاوكراني قالت مصادر
رسميه ان عدد القتلى في الجيش الاوكراني
بلغ قرابه 13 الفا في نهايه العام الماضي
بينما قدرت مصادر عسكريه امريكيه عدد
القتلى والجرح الاوكرانيين بنحو 100 الف
انسانيا تسببت الحرب في واحده من اكبر
ازمات النزوح البشري في العالم اذ بلغ عدد
اللاجئين الاوكرانيين زهاء ثمانيه ملايين
فضلا عن نحو سبعه ملايين من النازحين وذلك
وفقا للمفوضيه الساميه لشؤون اللاجئين كما
خلفت الحرب اثار اقتصاديه مدمره واعلن
رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني ان اضرارها على
البنيه التحتيه تجاوزت 7 مليار دولار
وقالت رئيسه صندوق النقد الدولي
كريستالينا ان اوكرانيا ستحتاج ما بين
ثلاثه مليارات واربعه مليارات دولار شهريا
في العام الجاري اما على الجانب الروسي
فقد تكبد الاقتصاد الروسي خسائر كبيره
جراء العقوبات الغربيه قدرتها وكاله
بلومبر بنحو 300 مليار دولار من ارصده
البنك المركزي الروسي المجمده في البنوك
الخارجيه وعلى الصعيد الدولي كلفت الحرب
الاقتصاد العالمي اكثر من تريليون و600
مليار دولار العام الماضي وفقا لدراسه
الاقتصاديه المانيه
كل فعاليه جدا عميد الياس حنا هل هل يمكن
ان تساهم في فرمله بعض الجنوح نحو مزيد من
تصعيد هذه الحرب وتوسيع مداها بالنسبه
للرئيس بوتين حسب ما شاهدنا منذ بدايه
الحرب هناك ما يسمى بالردع النووي
والتسكير فيه به على مراحل متعدده فقط
لحمايه العمليات التقليديه العسكريه ولكن
لمعرفه كيف يفكر يعني الرئيس بوتين وهو
يتحدث عن العقيده الروسيه النوويه يعني
يستعمل الجيش او استعمل النووي الروسي
عندما يكون هناك تهديد حتى ولو كان تقليدي
على الحدود المباشره لروسيا يهدد الامن
الداخلي ويتكلم عن وجود دوله ولكن هل
الدوله الروسيه الاتحاديه التي نعرفها قبل
الحرب ام الدوله بعد ان ضم اجزاء من
اوكرانيا هذا هو السؤال ما هنا عندما ضم
الاربع اقاليم اعتبرها ارض اوكرانيه فاذا
هي تدخل بطريقه غير مباشره ضمن العقيده
النوويه
ولكن لديه الفين سلاح تكتيكي راس تكتيكي
موجود ولكن الاستعمال على ساحه الاوكرانيه
يعني انت تريد الاستيلاء على هدف تدمره
ولا يمكن لك ان تذهب الى هذا الهدف بسبب
الاشعاعات اثنين يجب ان يكون العسكر
الاوكراني الروسي
ومجهزا في عتاده وتجهيزاته للسلاح النووي
والاهم محمد الموقف الصيني من هذا
الاستعمال يعني الصين يقول لا للاستعمال
ولا للتهديد به وهنا قد نفتح باب معين على
هل ستدخل الصين في المساعده التقليديه
لروسيه قد يكون هذا او يغير مسار اللعبه
لانه حتى اذا بقينا في الموضوع النووي
الخبير الامريكي جوزيف سيرينسيوني في صاحب
كتاب رعب القنبله مختص في هذا الموضوع حدد
اربع سيناريوهات لامكانيه الاستعمال
النووي الاول هو استعراض بسيط للقوه بمعنى
ضربات محدوده وتقنيه محدوده او استخدام
سلاح نووي منخفض الطاقه
او دخول الغرب مباشره في الحرب بمعنى ضربه
نوويه ورد نووي غربي او ضرب بلد اوروبي
غير اوكرانيا لكن الغريب انه مع كل هذه
السيناريوهات يقول هناك امكانيه ان يذهب
بوتين الى ان يحرق البيت كاملا
ويهدم المعبد على رؤوس من فيه ويقول هذا
احتمال او سيناريو لا نريد حتى ان نفكر
فيه من بينها ما الذي تراه ربما الاقرب
الى الواقعيه قد يكون يقال انه قد يكون
بتعليق العمل بمعاهده ستارت والاهم فيها
هي زيارات المتبادله بين الفريقين 18
زياده سنويا يعني العوده الى التجارب
النوويه بالحد الادنى
تفجير قنبله نوويه فوق البحر الاسود ولكن
استاذ محمد
الامر ليس بالسهل انت لديك النووي والفريق
الاخر لديه النووي وبالتالي اذا تذكرنا
تشرنوبيل الاشعاعات كانت بالاتجاه الروسي
والبيلاروسيا اكثر منها بالاتجاه الاوروبي
الامر ليس بالامر السهل وعندما يقول
الخبير التي تحدثت عنه انه قنبله بسيطه
اصغر قنبله تقليديه هي اكبر من قنبله انت
استعملت في نكازاكي وهيروشيما يعني هذا
الامر ليس بالامر المضبوط يعني لا انت لا
تستطيع هو ردع اساسي مهم جدا وانا لا
اعتقد ان الرئيس بوتين قد يذهب الى
الموضوع النووي ومن هنا الحديث الدائم عن
الاستعمال النووي لحمايه ما سيقوم به
بالمعنى التقليدي في الداخل وهو ايضا لديه
ما يسمى باب القنابل الكبرى مثل القنبله
الامريكيه
البومب يعني ام القنابل لديه قنبله هي
اكبر قنبله تقليديه اصغر من النووي لدى
الرئيس بوتين قد يستعملها في وقت من
الاوقات
اشرت الى الصين نريد ان نسل سيدروف عن
امكانيه دخول الصين بشكل مختلف طبعا في
دعم روسيا وبالتالي نذهب الى مزيد توسع
الحرب هذا اذا دون ان ننسى امكانيه الدخول
بيلاروسيا مولدوفيا وبالتالي
مدى امكانيه ان تتوسع
الحرب في عامها الثاني
نعم هذه الامكانيه موجوده وقائمه
واحتمالات يعني مثل هذا التطور عاليه ولكن
ليس عاليه جدا وانما عاليه بشكل نسبي انا
اعتقد بان بالنسبه للصين فالصين لها الان
كما تدل بعض المؤشرات يعني هناك
نيه او رغبه صينيه ربما في احتواء هذا
النزاع في احتواء الازمه الاوكرانيه عن
طريق ليس فقط طرح مبادره ومن المتوقع ان
تعلن الصين عنها يوم غد اي مرور سنه واحده
على بدء العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا ولكن وراء كل يعني امر او مبادره
سياسيه مصالح اقتصاديه مصلحه الصين في
وقفه يعني هذا هذه العمليه العسكريه
والاحتواء الازمه واضحه تماما وهي ان بعض
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه بدايتها تم
تدمير عدد من السلاسل اللوجيستيه وهي
بطبيعه الحال اثرت تاثيرا سلبيا للغايه
على الاقتصاد والتجاره الصينيه في وقت
بدات سن تتعافى بعد جائحه كورونا التي
تاثرت بها الصين بشكل ربما كبير جدا فهذا
ما يدفع القياده الصينيه الان الى طرحه
المبادرات الخاصه بالتسويه السياسيه
للازمه الاوكرانيه ونحن سمعنا ان حتى
اوكرانيا الان تريد ان يكون هناك لقاء قمه
بين الزعيمين الاوكراني زيلينسكي والصيني
شيرين هذا فلذلك كان الزعيم الصيني سوف
يزور روسيا خلال الربيع المقبل وبالتالي
نحن امام تطورات سياسيه مهمه طبعا يمكن ان
يتدخل هنا عنصر الم اذا تطورت العمليه
بشكل سريع جدا
وتزايدت حجم الامدادات الغربيه لاوكرانيا
في هذه الحاله قد تكون هناك مفاجات على
الجبهات الاوكرانيه لكن مع ذلك يبدو ان
الصين عازمه كل العزم على طرح موضوع
التسويه السياسيه وربما زيارتها الزعيم
الصيني سوف تكون لها دلالات بمعنى ان هذه
المبادره سيتم بلا شك الكشف عن محتواها
والمساله او السؤال الوحيد هو هل سوف يكون
هل سوف تكون هذه المبادره مقبوله لدى
الطرفي الصراع اي لدى موسكو وكيف لنرى
السيده سمنت ما اذا كانت ترى ان الصين
ستذهب في اتجاه الذي اشار اليه ضيفنا من
موسكو اتجاه المبادرات السياسيه اكثر من
الانخراط بشكل او باخر في تاييد روسيا عسك
ريا
نعم اتفق بصفه عامه مع ما تم قوله
اعتقد ان السياسه الخارجيه والسيد وانجي
المستشار السياسي لرئيس الوزراء كان في
موسكو وبعد ذلك كان في ميونخ والتقى بوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي وكان هناك الكثير من
التخمينات خصوصا في الغرب هذه التخمينات
التشيي بان الصين ربما قد تساعد روسيا من
الناحيه العسكريه لكن الصينيين وضحوا
المساله وبشكل جلي على انهم لن يساعدوا
روسيا من الناحيه العسكريه بالطبع الصين
وروسيا لديهما الكثير من الاعلانات
المرتبطه بالتعاون والصداقه وقاموا بتوقيع
اتفاق يتعلق بالصداقه ما بين البلدين
السنه الماضيه ولقد كذلك اكدت من الصين
وكذلك روسيا بمساعده بعضهم البعض لكن
الصينيون قاموا بازاله كلمه
المساعدات غير المحدوده او بدون حدود وهذا
يعني ان هذا يعتبر ربما تنزيل او تخفيف من
قيمه المساعدات التي ربما قد تتم بين
البلدين او مستوى المساعده ما بين البلدين
والتوقعات هي ان غدا ستخرج الصين بورقه
موقف ويبدو ان الترجمه من الصينيه الى
اللغه الانجليزيه ربما كانت غير واضحه
عندما تحدثوا عن خطه السلام هي ليست كذلك
هي ورقه موقف وبالتالي هم سيتحدثون عن
موقفهم تجاه هذه المساله هناك مساله لابد
ان نفهمها فيما يتعلق الامر بالصين
دائما متمسكه بفكره الوحده الاراضي هم
ليسوا مع فكره اقتراب او ان يكون هناك
استقلال بالنسبه لمناطق داخل دوله ما وذلك
يذكرهم بموقع تايوان هم دائما يؤكدون بان
تايوان هي جزء لا يتجزا من الصين وبالتالي
فان الصين لا تسمح بان يكون هناك اي ضم من
قبل روسيا وهذا يجعل موقفا الصين فعلا صعب
وبالتالي الصين بالتاكيد تريد ان تبعد
العالم من مفهوم عالم تسيطر عليه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لكن في الان ذاته دعم
روسيا يعني دعم سياسات لا تتفق الصين
بالضروره معها ولدينا كذلك
البعد الاقتصادي
والسياسي لان ربما قد يؤدي الى اضعاف
روسيا وهذه تكون فرصه لشراء شركات روسيه
وزياده الحضور والتواجد في منطقه سيبيريا
هذه العلاقه هي علاقه حساسه للصين اليد
العليا حولها مقارنه بروسيا اعتقد ان
الصين ربما قد تحصل او تقدم ربما بعض
الاسلحه لكن هناك بعض
الافكار بعض الاخبار التي تقول انها ربما
قد تحصل روسيا على اسلحه من كوريا
الشماليه لكن ربما قد تكون الموافقه ضمنيه
من قبل الصين لكن اتفق مع السيد سيدي رواف
عندما قال ان الصين لن تقف بالضروره وبقوه
امام او مع روسيا ربما لن تكون على الحياد
لكن لن تكون حليفه واضحه بالنسبه لروسيا
العميد لا يسهلنا ونحن نتحدث عن احتمالات
التوسع نطاق الحرب في عامها الثاني في
اوكرانيا هل تعتقد باننا قد نشهد استهداف
اكثر للاراضي الروسيه او استهداف حقيقي
للاراضي الروسيه لانه من الصعب ان تتوقف
موسكو اذا لم تشعر باضرار حقيقيه داخل
ترابها المعروف
سياسيا عن الاقل محمد هناك حربان تدوران
على المسرح الاوكراني
الجيش الروسي يخوت حرب شامله تعطي الورك
كما يقال هو يستهدف العسكر يستهدف المنشات
ويستهدف المدنيين وحتى البنى التحديه التي
يقوم عليها المجتمع المدني والهدف ان لا
تكون اوكرانيا دوله قابله للعيش في مرحله
لاحقا في المقابل يقود الاوكراني حربا
تقليديه على ارضه بالمبدا العام حسب
القانون الدولي وهو لا يستهدف الاراضي
الروسيه الا عرضا وبوسائل روسيه قديمه
سوفيتيه يملكها الجيش الاوكراني ولكنها
معدله من هنا استهداف بعض القواعد
العسكريه وحتى استهداف شبه جزيره القرم
فاذا نحن امام
تقيدات غربيه على اوكرانيا لعدم استعمالها
وسداد
يعني استهداف الاراضي الروسيه اليوم الهدف
الاوكراني تماما تماما هو استنزاف الجيش
الروسي في الداخل الاوكراني كي تكون
الكلفه عاليه الى درجه
تسعى الى تغيير سياسي في الداخل التاريخ
الروسي يقوم على
التعثر العسكري في الخارج الى تغيير سياسه
في الداخل هذا الامر ليس قريبا في روسيا
حاليا يعني في الحرب ضد اليابان البحريه
اتت الثوره البرشفيه في افغانستان بريجنيف
تم التغيير بالسلطه اليوم يسعى هذا الامر
الى رفع المستوى العسكري ولكن او المستوى
الكلفه العسكريه للرئيس ولكن يبدو من
خطابه الاخيره اسبرين انه يعد المجتمع
الروسي لحرب طويله ويعتبر نفسه ان الوقت
يعمل لصالحه وبالتالي عمليه الاستنزاف
ستكون لاوكرانيا ولاراده الغرب وماذا عن
رئيس جديد في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
كيف سيكون عليه الوضع
الكل يقول الان ان الغرب لا مصلحه له ولا
يريد ان تتحول هذه الحرب الى مواجهه
مباشره ومفتوحه بين الولايات المتحده
وروسيا رغم انها بشكل او باخر هي كذلك
ولكن على الاقل بالمعنى المباشر الغرب لا
يريدها ان تصبح كذلك مواجهه بين الناتو
وبين روسيا ولكن ما هي النقطه العسكريه
الحاسمه التي عندها ربما قد يمكن الحديث
عن توقف هذه الحرب او عند عندها يمكن ان
نشرع في الحديث عن تسويه ما
محمد دائما الذهاب الى طاوله المفاوضات
عندما يقتنع الافرقه ان هذا اقصى ما يمكن
له ان يحققه يمكن تسويقه في الداخل
وبالتالي هذه الخساره اصبحت الى درجه
متقدمه لا تبرر الاهداف او سعر الاهداف
الموجوده انا قلت اليوم اولويات الرئيس
بوتين بالحد الادنى الاربع اقاليم
بالاضافه الى اقليم شبه جزيره القرم
وبالتالي بالنسبه لاوكرانيا ان يكون هناك
نصر بالحد الادنى الوصول الى شواطئ البحر
الاسود وبالتالي تهديد شبه جزيره القرم
والذهاب الى طاوله المفاوضات ونحن في هذه
المرحله وتحدثنا عنها في بدايه الحلقه في
هذه المرحله الاستعداد الاوكراني يجري
لهذا السيناريو والاستعداد الروسي
والتنفيذ الروسي يجري للسيطره على اقليم
دومباس او على ما تبقى من الاقاليم
الاربعه التي ضمها الرئيس بوتين لو اردنا
في نهايه هذه الحلقه ان نقوم بجوله سنبدا
بالسيدروف ثم السيده ديبندر ثم ننهي
بالعميد الياس حنا
بشكل مختصر سيد رواف ما الذي تتوقعه كتغير
كبير في العام الثاني للحرب
في عجاله انا اتوقع ان هذا التغير ستتمصل
ربما في الاسراع في يعني معدلات وو طائره
العماليه العسكريه الروسيه
لتحقيق الهدف الاساسي على الاقل في هذه
المرحله وهما السيطره على منطقه بما فيها
ولكن هناك نقطه مهمه جدا عدد من التصريحات
التي ادلى بها القيادات الروسيه جاء فيها
انه كلما ازدادت او اتسع حجم الامدادات
الغربيه للاسلحه كلما ستكون روسيا مضطره
لابعاد الخطر الذي يخيم عليها وهو خطر
الوجود في بعض الحالات الى ما هو ابعد
يعني هذا هذه التصريحات تتضمن تلقيح الى
امكانيه الاستمرار في هذه العمليه حتى بعد
السيطره على دول باص لنرى باختصار شديد
سيده بندان
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان الكثير من الاشياء تعتمد على ما
سيحدث في روسيا واريد ان اذكر المشاهدين
في العشر سنوات في حرب روسيا وافغانستان
كان هناك 15 الف من الروس الذين توفوا
واذا ما اخذنا الوفيات التي تعلنها روسيا
والتي لا يصدقها اي شخص لانها تقترب من
مئه الف والتي يؤكد عليها كل المراقبين
الدوليين تخيلوا 100 الف من الموت مقارنه
بخمسه عشر الف في عشر سنوات فان سقوط
الاتحاد السوفياتي جاء بسبب الخساره التي
حدثت في افغانستان وان السكان في الاتحاد
السوفياتي سائم سائم من تلك الحرب
وبالتالي فان الروس هم يسالون ان لم يكن
هناك تغيير في هذه الحرب حرب العدوان ربما
قد نرى في 2023
استمرار حرب استنزاف حرب تكون الخطوط
تتحرك فيها بشكل بطيء
هناك سباق مع الوقت الرئيس بوتين يصطبق
الاستعداد الاوكراني وبالتالي يحاول تحقيق
اكبر قدر من الممكن من الانتصارات الجيش
الاوكراني يسعى الى الصمود بانتظار العتاد
مع استنزاف وانزال اكبر قدر من الخسائر
بالجيش الروسي للمرحله القادمه شكرا جزيلا
لك العميد الياس حنا لحضورك معنا هنا في
الاستوديو شكرا
سيدهم من باريس شكرا سيد ايفيني من موسكو
كالعاده نصل في نهايه هذا الحلقه لتغريدات
حول موضوع هذه الحلقه نبداها بتغريده
لرئيس المجلس الاوروبي يقول فيها بعد مرو
على بدء روسيا حربها العدوانيه لا يزال
عزم الاتحاد الاوروبي ثابتا سوف نتاكد من
تحقيق النصر لاوكرانيا واستعاده وحده
اراضيها واعاده بناء البلاد وتحقيق
العداله وحتى ذلك الحين لن يهدا لنا بال
من جانبها قالت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ارسل لها نحن معكم كنا معكم في هذه
المعركه الوجوديه منذ البدايه اصبحت
اوكرانيا مركز قارتنا المكان الذي يتم فيه
دعم قيمنا حيث يتم الدفاع عن حريتنا حيث
يكتب مستقبل اوروبا
البيت الابيض في صفحته على تويتر كتب بعد
مرور عام على دخول الدبابات الروسيه الى
اوكرانيا لا تزال اوكرانيا مستقله وحره
ستواصل الولايات المتحده العمل مع حلفائها
وشركائها للوقوف ضد العدوان الروسي وتقديم
دعما حاسم لشعب اوكرانيا البعثه الروسيه
لدى الامم المتحده كتبت اليوم وبعد عاما
واحدا من دخول الازمه الاوكرانيه مرحلتها
الناشطه ليس هناك شك في ان اوكرانيا ليست
هي من يقاتل روسيا بل الغرب مجتمعا
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها في النيتو
والاتحاد الاوروبي ونختم بتغريده للامم
المتحده نقلا عن امينها العام انطونيو
يقول فيها لم نشهد تزايد المعاناه والدمار
فحسب بل اصبح ايضا اكثر وضوحا الى اي مدى
يمكن ان يصبح الامر اسوا
دمتم في رعايه الله والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]